let me be very clear here tonight this
is a big deal number one all of us all
of you have been lied to by Joe Biden
and the Biden Administration and their
inability to safeguard this country's
most sensitive Secrets this is a clear
and present danger a major threat to our
national security by the way a major
threat for our allies National Security
by the way it gives Vladimir Putin I
know the Biden family Syndicate loves to
do business with Russia and Putin it
gives them critical intelligence that
they would not have otherwise had and
worst of all it exposed that Joe Biden
authorized putting U.S Special Forces on
the ground in Ukraine and lied to we the
American people we should have known
about some of this they should have at
least gone through Congress and this
needs to be gotten to the bottom of
these documents exposed our entire
Ukraine war strategy our level of
involvement it revealed that there are
the special forces stationed at the
embassy in Ukraine they gave the
location of where our forces are well
that means that makes them a target of
Vladimir Putin they uncovered
information of U.S spies that they have
obtained about Russia and the uae's
strengthening relationship with Russia
by the way Saudi Arabia Egypt the UAE
they have all abandoned the Coalition
under Donald Trump and they are betting
on China not on the United States to be
the world's largest superpower but while
the Fallout continues what's Joe doing
what's your president doing well he's
out there touring Ireland joking about
wishing that he didn't have to return
home Joe you can stay there as long as
you want
you can move into an Irish Pub as far as
I'm concerned stay there we will be
better off when asked about the league
today your president literally just
brushed it aside added a bizarre comment
about why I got to go plant a tree and
this should worry every American because
this is a serious significant dangerous
intelligence leak that never should have
happened but it did they allowed it to
happen take a look
okay
[Music]
How concerned are you about this league
are you concerned about our
relationships it's time to go let's go
oh we got to move I'm not concerned
about the laziness and I'm concerned
that it happened but there's nothing
contemporaneous that I'm aware of that
is of good country no Joe is lying he is
wrong our strategy for an ongoing War uh
isn't uh contemporaneous apparently
protecting our nation's very sensitive
intelligence is not a high priority for
him uh he's too busy planting trees uh
and visiting castles in Ireland but we
could have guessed that after all he let
that Chinese spy balloon collecting
intelligence and relaying it back to
China in real time fly all across the
continental U.S all over Alaska airspace
all over our sensitive military sites
but don't worry let not your heart be
troubled because while our nation's
Secrets will be being exposed to the
world Joe had a great day in Ireland
where he was chasing balls around at a
youth sporting event yesterday he took
questions not from the Press but from
children and even there his son Hunter
who shouldn't even be there should be in
jail had to save him anyway and then he
was barked at by the president of
Ireland's dog
I'm guessing the dog likely perceived
that creepy Joe would show up and might
smell his hair
of course uh well that all got lost
multiple times when trying to pose for
pictures but somehow he also found the
time and his busy schedule to make many
bizarre rambling nonsensical insane
speeches that we've all come to admire
so much that has now initiated and
motivated our geopolitical foes to
create alliances to basically replace
the U.S as the world's leader take a
look
forestry reminds us
our history ours yours and mine reminds
of the responsibilities we have to the
president that should be the president
our courage
our creativity
our loyalty our tenacity
and our loyalty again the only thing I
bring to this career after my age as you
can see
how old I am
a little bit of wisdom
I come to the job with more experience
than any president of American History
doesn't make me better or worse
but it gives me a few excuses I said pop
what do you worry about he said you're
too much
you're too much like that guy who led
the revolution instead of the guy who
was the Prime Minister
he said you got to be less like
a military guy they shot him he'd look
at me saying Joe remember
who you are like you're abiding like you
know what the hell the Biden you know I
mean I'm like like I'm a you know anyway
thank you all God bless you all let's go
let's go lick the world let's get it
done
that's your President right there now In
fairness Joe did eventually address the
dangers to the U.S including the most
pressing uh threat that we now have
climate change take a look
the single existential threat to the
world
is climate change
we don't have a lot of time and that's a
fact
they're even recognizing finally
everyone's recognizing America no it's
not the new axis of Evil of China Russia
Iran it's not the fact that the Saudis
have joined with China have made an
alliance with the Iranians are making an
alliance with the syrians it has nothing
to do with the fact that Egypt is now
aligned with Putin nothing to do with
the fact that we discovered through this
document leak an intelligence leak that
in fact the UAE they too have abandoned
us they're moving towards China they
think China is going to win this
conflict because America doesn't have a
president that knows what day of the
week it is hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else